bis repetita pour le sport amateur ce
nouveau confinement va une nouvelle fois
perturbé la pratique sportive pendant au
minimum quatre semaines pour les sports
en intérieur la fédération française de
handball avait été l'une des premières a
été la compétition au moins jusqu'en
décembre
tout comme la fédération française de
volley-ball pour le basket les
compétitions stop également jusqu'à
cette période mais les dirigeants
s'attendent à un redémarrage des
compétitions pour le début d'année
prochaine
la fédération de basket à au moins dit
qu' il y aurait une inertie de quinze
jours quand les rencontres pourrait
reprendre pour permettre aux équipes de
se ré entraîner les de manière à assurer
une certaine équité sportive et surtout
une intégrité physique de la part de
tous les sportifs qui lui a quelques
sous et quel que soit le niveau auquel
ils jouent pour le football ce mercredi
matin la fédération française a annoncé
la suspension des compétitions de ligue
2 districts des championnats nationaux
d'une nationale 2 et 3 ainsi que la
coupe de france et les championnats
nationaux jeunes
cette mesure s'appliquera au minimum
jusqu'au 1er décembre un casse tête en
vue pour les instances ça pose la
question on n'a pas encore pris de
décision mais on va y réfléchir
maintenant c'est les coupes
parce qu'on a les championnats la côte
est mais les coupes des yvelines d'autre
part on avait déjà les coupes les coupes
futsal
qui était qu'ils allaient comme futsal
seniors qui avait dont il avait été
décidé qu'elle n'aurait pas lieu
maintenant la question va se poser pour
l'ensemble des coupes de toutes les
catégories les seniors les u18 les u16
du14 les féminines et c'est parce qu'il
va falloir sans doute se consacrer
uniquement au championnat
le rugby amateur se met également en
pause jusqu'à début janvier au minimum
la fédération a également annoncé
l'annulation des phases finales pour
permettre aux championnats de se jouer
jusqu'au bout pour éviter la saison
blanche nous faisions contrefont de
mauvaise fortune bon coeur en ayant là
encore la possibilité de jouer désormais
il faut vous participer à l'effort
national
le plus dur reste à venir maintenant de
rester compétitif de garder le contact
avec nos licenciés nos partenaires seule
interrogation la pratique ou non du
sport par les mineurs il pourrait
participer à des entraînements
le sujet est encore sur la table